joining us now the host of CRT V Levin
TV and the host of life liberty and
Levin right here on the Fox News Channel
as a matter of fact this weekend
governor Palin is going to be your guest
on the show I've always liked governor
Palin and we haven't heard from her in a
while
I look forward to watching mark all
right so the big question now is what
the president needs to do apparently the
president's lawyers are negotiating with
the special counsel over the idea that
the president would speak with Robert
Muller the President himself is like I
have nothing to hide I did speak with
them but if there's no underlying crime
if collusion is not a crime and the
president is the right to fire call me
or anybody else and even Comey admitted
as much then the question is you know if
they want to get into the president's
mindset your thoughts can't represent a
crime in my opinion you're the
constitutional expert would you allow
the president was your client would you
allow him to speak to robert muller no
and let me tell you i wouldn't allow him
to speak for his sake and for the sake
of the office of the presidency because
this is a rogue prosecutor who's
investigating nothing you understand
that he's investigating nothing there's
no underlying crime when he got his
appointment by the Deputy Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General did
not provide any basis for the
appointment that is he didn't say here
the criminal statutes I want you
investigate because there aren't any I
want to make a point that I don't
believe anybody else is made and this is
very very important for the President
and for the president's lawyers in the
nation the official position of the
United States Department of Justice
under a Democrat administration and a
Republican administration was set out by
the Office of Legal Counsel that's the
constitutional office within the
Department of Justice in to memorandum
and these memoranda say that a president
United States cannot be indicted while
he's in office cannot be indicted while
he's in office so he can't be a criminal
target president the United States can't
be a criminal target because he can't be
indicted that's the official position of
mr. Muller's bosses over there at the
Department of Justice that's number one
number
- I keep hearing but what if he
subpoenaed to appear before the grand
jury subpoena to appear before the grand
jury well then you go to the federal
judge and you say to the federal judge
Your Honor my client can't be indicted
that's the position of his bosses so why
is he going in front of a federal grand
jury well we need him as a witness a
witness to what what criminal statute or
what criminal violations do you think he
was a witness to that he needs to
testify - well we think he may have
committed obstruction and even though we
may not charge him excuse me mr. Muller
this is a criminal grand jury this isn't
being done so you can issue your report
so there are many constitutional
obstacles of course to this argument
that the president obstructed justice
so firing a subordinate is obstructing
justice that's absurd if that's
obstructing justice then when mr. Muller
fired mr. stroke maybe that's
obstruction of justice - interfering
with an investigation what I'm saying is
when I watch people come on TV and say
well he could be subpoenaed well anybody
can be subpoenaed
he's the President of the United States
and you damn well better have a strong
reason for trying to drag him in front
of a grand jury that's number one number
two a federal judge is not going to just
accept that kind of a spectacle mr.
Muller knows it that's why they're
trying to negotiate reach some kind of a
deal you're gonna drag a president who's
dealing with all these issues all over
the world who's dealing with China and
Russia North Korea in Iran and so forth
and so on and bring him in front of a
grand jury a judge is not going to want
that kind of a constitutional crisis
that's why mr. Muller is trying to
negotiate some basis to interview mr.
Trump but if I were mr. Trump I'd say
you know what I didn't do anything wrong
and that's exactly why I'm not talking
to you
that's number one I'm gonna protect this
office for Democrats and Republicans who
are elected president of the United
States that's number two and you have
crimes that you want to prosecute go for
it baby but I didn't commit a crime I'm
not going to be indicted I'm not gonna
be dragged in front of a federal grand
jury and that's that that's what the
president's are saying let me ask you
this next question because I think this
is key and there's been very few of us
that have done this deep dive into this
I would argue corrupt
team that robert Muller's put together
everyone say he is beyond reproach well
I look at his handling in the anthrax
case post 9/11 I look at you know the
case when he was in Boston as it relates
to Whitey Bulger four innocent people
went to jail a hundred plus million
dollar settlement two of those guys two
of the four died in jail then you got
this guy Andrew Weissman the New York
Times calls a Muller's pit ball okay
that's a guy that as a result of his
actions twice was excoriated by judges
for withholding exculpatory evidence
tens of thousands of jobs were lost at
anderson accounting for no reason at all
over turn nine zero in the Supreme Court
you and I both know that doesn't happen
a lot and a guy that sent for Merrill
executives to jail mark for for a year
and that was overturned by the Fifth
Circuit wait a minute why would Robert
Muller with his background be appointing
only Obama only hillary only DNC donors
and corrupt people like Weisman to his
team to be his put and why and why are
the Democrats so keen on him and why are
the media so keen on him and there's
lots of leaks coming out of that
separation to among them to the
Washington Post the other day is he
wants to put a report out by June or
July where they're probably going to
suggest the president United States
committed obstruction of justice not
only is that outrageous so the extent he
does a report it's supposed to be to the
Deputy Attorney General on the crimes
he's found or the crimes he's
prosecuting he's not supposed to give
opinions let's be clear about something
the media treat this guy like he's a
judge he's not a judge he's a prosecutor
and there's two sides to every argument
that's number one number two he's gonna
put out a report accusing the President
of the United States of obstruction of
justice when in fact that means that the
president United States will be accused
of obstruction of justice for
impeachment purposes that leak should
tell the president United States
everything he needs to know which is
that Muller is out to destroy him was
out to write a report to give it to the
Democrats in the House of
Representatives they'll have a little
over a minute left and I would argue
he'll be stepping right into a perjury
trap if there's no underlying crime and
they can't indict the president defend
the off
to the presidency and defend yourself
well said
that's why we call you the great one rod
Rosenstein it I he shouldn't even be in
this position number one number two
isn't he conflicted out of he's the
number one witness as it relates to
obstruction would call me because he
wrote a letter recommending such and in
fact he signed on to this extended this
FISA warrant himself knowing that this
was bought and paid for Hillary
propaganda Russian lies and then
appoints Muller how does he get away
with that conflict how does he get how
do you see him in all this I see him as
very bizarre and really out of line
in addition everything you said we now
know that when Muller went into mr.
Manfred's apartment at 5:00 or 6:00 in
the morning when he and his wife were in
bed with the fbi's with their guns drawn
and he got a warrant from a federal
judge when he went in there gathered
information and then got went then he
goes to the Deputy Attorney General a
week later to have his authority
expanded to cover what he had just done
a week before so mister Rosenstein
expands his authority to cover the
tracks from Muller who was doing things
he shouldn't have done and the reason
why this is important America is this
mr. Rosenstein is now the Attorney
General of the United States well is
acting like it alright Sunday night
10:00 p.m. Life Liberty Levin governor
Palin will be marched guests